what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the immortal X-Men
specifically the fullon return of
apocalypse which technically he's been
back since the last video that we made
but we get to see him in All His glory
so this is the portion of fall of X that
focuses on the 250,000 mutants that were
whisked away to some unknown location
now a lot of you guys said you thought
it was the other dimensional realm of
oraco those of you guys who are familiar
with everything that's been happening in
the X-Men since John than Hickman's
original run that's not where they're at
and in fact they're in a really really
cool location but what we know is that
within this kind of desert realm that
they've been in they have essentially
been attacked by different versions of
wolver rain these almost kind of feral
versions of wolverin which we thought
were like the Clones of Wolverine from
The Wolverine solo series when Beast was
making like you know clones of Wolverine
and then attacking humanity and that
kind of thing if you're not familiar
with that it's not overly important what
does matter here is that during this
time after this initial reprieve with
these pot shots that are constantly
being taken right these different
versions of Wolverine just seemingly
keep coming after them the what we end
up doing is picking up with the
resurrection of one of these mutants a
member of the five using a resurrection
egg now the resurrection egg is the way
in which mutants basically bring
themselves back from the dead these
things were thought to have been
completely and totally destroyed during
the fall of kcoa but there is one with
enough to bring a single mutant back and
what this does is it completes the five
in essence what it does is it allows any
of the X-Men here to basically be
resurrected the only caveat is they need
an egg to do it so if they don't have an
egg there's no real way to bring them
back but what this does establish is
that Resurrection is still an option on
the table once everything returns to a
state of normaly but the person who was
able to pull this off with Mother
righteous who's basically a clone of the
villain Mr Sinister albeit a female
version and one that delves in Magic she
does have mutant abilities but she's
also very duplicitous right she always
has an ulterior motive there's always
something else going on so even when you
have Destiny right the woman who can see
the future right even when she looks at
mother righteous she's like I don't
fully trust her now before people who
were unfamiliar with the X-Men asked if
she can see the future wouldn't she know
whether or not mother righteous is going
to betray them that's a fair question
but that we've talked about so much in
the X-Men Comics the accuracy of Destiny
predictions become less and less right
they become less and less accurate the
further out she looks so even if Mother
righteous is going to betray them all
there's no guarantee that it's going to
happen but even beyond that right the
entire group is led by Exodus and while
Exodus is an astronomically powerful
telepath and telekinetic he sees himself
as the kind of person leading the mutant
population right now in his mind there's
no room for doubters so even when
Destiny comes along and says right like
I don't know if I fully trust her the
response of Exodus is enough right like
she's useful she's returned the five to
us she has returned immortality to us is
a professional jealousy her Visions are
true you have none what use are you now
so it's one of those things where he
kind of approaches it from the
perspective of saying like you're just
pissed off right you're just jelly
because she can see the future and you
can't right like it's kind of
interesting but the reality here is that
Destiny is not somebody that you dismiss
even if her power isn't what it used to
be or even if it's not there at all if
she has a gut feeling you usually go
with it right she's the kind of person
within the X-Men Universe whose
predictions or viewpoints are kind of
Beyond contestation so it almost sort of
gives this idea that Exodus is not
really thinking clearly or rationally
and there's a reason for that because
what they're told by mother righteous is
that there is another Vision she had
right somebody else another lost mutant
out in the woods not the literal woods
but just out there in this place that
they're at and so what you end up
getting is Exodus along with Hope
Summers that basically travel to try to
find this mutant now this is where
things get cool at this point you switch
over to Charles Xavier now as we talked
about in the previous X-Men comics and
in the immortal X-Men comic itself
Xavier is staying on the island of kakoa
trying to protect it from anybody out
there that would try to plunder its
riches or disrespect it in any capacity
or anything like that and so what ended
up happening is Sebastian Shaw who was
at one point a member of the governing
body of the X-Men but is now one of the
people trying to plunder this place keep
sending soldiers in but they keep
getting massacred right and the response
here is that we thought it was Charles
Xavier but his power is telepathy not
telekinesis and so while he can cast
delusions to trick people into thinking
they're seeing gigantic monsters there
was no real tangible or reasonable
explanation for why these soldiers
bodies were found Torn to Pieces and so
what you end up getting is a combination
of Sebastian Shaw Dawning a kind of iron
manes armor for himself as well as
Seline launching an attack against
Xavier now as we talked about before of
course Seline she's a really old mutant
she basically feeds off the life
energies of other people in order to
keep herself alive but she's very
capable and she's very powerful but when
they launch their attack against Xavier
it's more than he can cope with on his
own so telepathically he reaches out to
Emma Frost who's doing her whole thing
in the Iron Man comics and once the two
of them start talking she asked the
question what is it that Sebastian Shaw
wants and that's when she telepathically
shows him Sebastian Shaw was kicked out
of the hellfire club right and that
while Wilson fist Kingpin had taken his
place Sebastian Shaw is trying to find a
way to get back in and so using that
information Professor Xavier
telepathically contacts Sebastian Shaw
and says look here's the deal I've
harvested p passwords for a dozen key
Hellfire accounts you can use them to
start to Take Back Control it'll be a
battle but this is enough of a win if
you act now go recover your Club kakoa
will still be here when you're done
right so it's kind of a way to sort of
create a bit of a ceasefire there and so
Sebastian Shaw realizing this
opportunity fires on Seline and then
says well you know he he took over my
mind there's nothing I can do right
which is enough to knock Seline out in
the moment kind of put her out a Capac
capity and then in turn you have him who
takes Seline he leaves and then he
basically uses the information Xavier
gave him to go after the hellfire club
here's the kicker to it all he makes
this kind of off-handed remark right he
says like I understand it's a deal God
Xavier I hate to think what we've
Unleashed you were always a manipulative
guy but murderous you is something else
I think even Cen squirmed when she saw
the bodies and the response of Xavier is
I don't understand what you're talking
about I haven't killed anybody which
begs the question who was killing the
soldiers on the island so what this does
here is it switches back over to Hope
Summers and to Exodus as well as Jean
Gray right genan gray is technically
dead and nobody really knows where these
guys are right now but what ends up
happening here is that Hope Summers goes
to read the mind of Jean because Jean is
just kind of like going on and babbling
on about nonsense right like but he
couldn't survive the Phoenix not him not
even Scott my distant passionate Scott
in my reality I steered the shuttle I
called for help I let the Phoenix have
me that's not when I went wrong right
and it's just kind of her being
delirious and sort of struggling this is
actually all playing out in the Gan gray
solo comic by Louis Simson it's really
really cool but it's also really slow so
I'm not 100% sure if I'm going to cover
it or not but in this moment you have
hope who asked the question we're
missing something this is where we're
supposed to be what are we missing
that's what apocalypse shows back up and
he says like you're Satan and he attacks
Exodus now the reason why he refers to
himself as his Satan and the reason why
he looks the way he does is because this
is how he originally appeared to Exodus
so for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with the character of Exodus
and Marvel Comics this guy fought during
the Crusades that's how old he is he's
been around for hundreds of years but
originally he was just a guy named
Bennett but what ended up happening is
that in a pursuit of a quote unquote
greater destiny word had reached his
ears of a person out there in Egypt that
could Grant him the destiny he was
looking for and when he got there he was
met by apocalypse apocalypse Unleashed
or kind of woke up his telepathic and
telekinetic abilities and then
ultimately Exodus turned against
apocalypse apocalypse overpowered him
and then locked him away a few hundred
years later he was released he initially
started off as a villain and then he
became a good guy but he sees apocalypse
as the worst thing to ever happen
happened to him he despises and he hates
apocalypse much in the same way Sinister
does and so as they're talking
apocalypse keeps making these statements
right he says prideful grandiosity was
always on your list of sents I am who
you say I am here that is true we are in
your desert right the desert that Exodus
always thought of whenever it was he was
thinking about his time with apocalypse
what this means is this location that
they're in it's malleable it's not a
finite place they're not out in the
Sahara they're not out in orocco they're
in a location which changes and adjust
based on the thought process of the
person in it and specifically what seems
to be the most dominant person in it and
so where the questions asked by hope
like what is this guy on about Exodus
responds I know not I had visions of
this place long ago and he is right I
think of him as my Satan but what you
end up having is Hope Summer that comes
to this realization Logan she sees Logan
as Logan killed her she sees Bishop as
Bishop hunted her and now apocalypse
exodus's Satan is in exodus's desert
right and that's what apocalypse is like
Revelation awaits girl are you ready and
so what she does is she scans the mind
of Jean Gray and while there is a kind
of telepathic feedback she responds and
saying I'm okay but Jean Gray is not her
mind is on fire it's burning so hot
Beyond hot so I know where we are I
don't know what it means but I know and
she asked the question what's the white
hot room they're in the white hot room
son and I don't know what it is man but
Marvel has hardcore been focusing on the
white hot room right where the white
Phoenix of the crown resides if ever
there were a time where Jean Gray would
go back to the height of her power this
would be it because when Jean Gray was
the White Phoenix of the crown she was
powerful than pretty much any and all
Cosmic entities out there I would argue
she was more powerful than the Living
Tribunal we never actually saw them
fight and I don't think there's really
any indication that she definitively was
but outside of like any illusions that
were created right here comes tomorrow
that she exists to quote unquote fix
universes things like that that she can
meddle with she can eradicate whole
universes if she wants to with that
level of power yeah man I would say that
she's probably a little bit above if not
equal to to The Living Tribunal if she
attains that level of power here if she
realizes who she is and the Phoenix REM
merges with her in the white hot room
she's going to turn into god with a
quickness and so what we end up doing is
jumping back to Professor Exavier the
mystery that so many of you guys have
been chomping at the bit for right
there's this kind of monologue that we
get which is really more kind of
Apocalypse musing to himself with
everything that was going on out in the
white hot room but sort of applies here
where he says no one survives Revelation
the person you were is dead and gone
forever in their place perhaps someone
stronger perhaps no one at all in the
end there is only Revelation itself and
Revelation cannot be denied in essence
Professor Xavier is seemingly the one
who's been killing the soldiers on the
island but he's infected with the
Sinister Gene meaning he's becoming an
evil version of himself self and most
likely he's developed a more advanced
version of telekinesis because he does
have it it's just very very subtle it
seems like it's become a lot more
powerful right the plot thickens with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you need to get
caught up on fex make sure you click
this link to the playlist and I will
catch you all later peace